[Musique]
si jusqu'à aujourd'hui les températures
sont restées clémente en alsace l'hiver
ne passera pas sans son cortège de
chutes de neige et de verglas dans le
haut comme tous les ans on se prépare
pour la viabilité hivernale des routes
en tout ce sont cinquante cinq engins et
220 personnes qui seront mobilisés pour
surveiller et traiter quelque 2500 km de
voies départementales
l'année dernière le dispositif avec
l'aube allemand bien fonctionné alors
cette année on reprend le même le
dispositif qui va être mis en place pour
l'hiver 2018 2019 sera sensiblement le
même que celui qu'on a mis en place pour
l'année 2017 2018 et donc qui concerne
donc que toutes les routes
départementales du haut rhin seront à la
fois traitées lors qu'il y aura du
verglas et deuxièmement lorsqu'il à des
phénomènes d'enneigement
toutes les routes seront traitées mais
en deux étapes une étape des réseaux
prioritaire ce que nous venons nous
devions faire dans tous les cas et puis
dans un deuxième temps le réseau ce
qu'on appelle secondaires qui lui si je
me réfère à ce qu'on avait prévu au
départ n'aurait jamais été ni leininger
nissan le territoire un certain nombre
d'actes structurants qui permettent les
échanges et les déplacements entre les
principaux pôles d'activité
ceux ci sont définis prioritaire pour le
traitement en cas de grand froid
l'idée c'est de s'assurer qu'ils soient
praticables tôt le matin pour permettre
aux rhinois télétravail et c'est déjà
tout ce qu'on appelle les deux fois deux
voies c'était un des grands axes comme
la rd 430 la la rd83 le relais des axes
principaux qui qui partagent dans le
département ensuite c'est tous les axes
importants je parle ça la montée du
bonhomme je pense à la desserte berck
aux vins de colmar neuf brisach vers
fribourg offert vers l'allemagne
enfin c to c haque cela qu'ils sont des
axes je veux dire à la fois prioritaire
pour nous je pense aussi bien sur ce
qu'on appelle l' ouvrage strauss qui est
la leur et la route qui va du sundgau
vers verbale qui est très fréquentée en
plus de bonne heure le matin
donc ça c'est vraiment des axes
prioritaires pour nous et que nous
traitons bien sûr très tôt à partir de 5
heures du matin voire pour les deux fois
deux voies toute la nuit
ainsi en cas de fortes chutes de neige
chaque village disposera d'un accès au
réseau routier praticable le matin voilà
pour le réseau tee prioritaire le réseau
dit secondaire sera lui traité dans la
journée si le phénomène neigeux se
poursuit c'est là que cela se complique
pour bien comprendre rien ne vaut un
exemple si on a un phénomène neigeux la
nuit le matin on dégage les routes
prioritaires et les villages ont
systématiquement un littéraire qui a
déneigé
ensuite si dans la journée il n'y a pas
d'autres phénomènes neigeux
on va faire le reste bdo départementale
et puis voilà ça continue admettons que
dans la journée il ya un deuxième
phénomène neigeux et qu'on n'ait pas eu
le temps de faire le réseau secondaire
à ce moment là on peut être amené à
refaire le jeu réseau prioritaire avant
d'intervenir sur le réseau secondaire si
le sel est très efficace pour empêcher
les routes de geler il est aussi très
mauvais pour l'environnement pour vous
en rendre compte
il vous suffit de sel est régulièrement
votre jardin vos plantations
n'apprécions guère ce geste
autant vous dire que sur un hiver ou
parlant tonnes de sel déversées sur les
routes sous forme de saumur de façon
générale on essaie d'en limiter l'emploi
et sur les zones sensibles
on trouve des solutions alternatives
dans mon canton dans le canton de
guebwiller on a
l'exemple bien précis c'est la montée
vers le markstein que nous n'avons pas
le droit de salé du tout puisque
l'alimentation en eau potable du bassin
versant de guebwiller est alimentée par
le lac de la lauch et donc pas de sel
pour ne pas polluer la rivière et puis
le captage qui est en contrebas et donc
du coût de la cdu c'est du gravillonnage
systématiquement donc la lame passe pour
le déneiger et ensuite la en gravillons
derrière pour que l'adhérence pour les
véhicules soit un peu plus plus plus
important on essaie d'économiser au
maximum déchets le sel parce que c'est
pas très bon pour la nature
si le conseil départemental vous assure
que les routes soient praticables en
hiver le premier responsable de sa
sécurité c'est le conducteur lui même il
n'est jamais inutile de le rappeler
ni même de dispenser quelques conseils
de bonne pratique pas des bonnes
pratiques c'est d'avoir des voitures
déjà très bien entretenu un qui son
point de vue entretien soit au top
évidemment on préconise d'avoir un
maximum d'équipements de neige ou deux
au moins quatre saisons parce que
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que pour les gens
qui vont travailler de bonne heure le
matin quand il ya eu un phénomène
neigeux
c'est quand même plus sécurisant et donc
voilà c'est ce que c'est ce qui se
pratique en allemagne s'est passé pas le
cas chez nous mais je pense que c'est
tout à fait recommandable pour ceux qui
travaillent de bonne heure le matin
enfin pour partir serein le matin il
faut être bien informé sur l'état du
réseau
l'ensemble des infos de circulation sont
transmises en temps réel par le service
des routes mais un site internet sur le
département et on à inforoute 68
il donne toutes les informations et en
plus on a aussi france bleu qui fait des
messages tous les matins 7 heures du
matin
un peu plus tard pour informer sur
l'état des routes sur les travaux qui
sont pratiqués dans la certains endroits
et ses terres dans les prochains jours
pas d'épisode neigeux prévu
vous pouvez dormir tranquille mais
n'oubliez pas la prudence ce n'est pas
que quand il ya du verglas
c'est toute l'année